lassen sie nicht von der laune hier
nicht täuschen auch in dieser woche
dreht sich medial fast alles um das
corona virus leipziger buchmesse
abgesagt reisemesse igb abgesagt
hannover messe verschoben zum glück ist
die erotikmesse venus erst im oktober
ja ich habe einen eigenen stand ist egal
ist ja auch egal und auch wenn die
deutschen immer noch relativ ruhig
bleiben gibt es erste vorboten von
endzeitstimmung stichwort hamsterkäufe
hamsterkäufe was das denn für ein
quatsch konserven nudeln alles wird
gebunkert was dann besonders begehrt vor
allem auf ein produkt scheinen es die
hamsterkäufe besonders abgesehen zu
haben
thema talent man braucht man braucht
toilettenpapier ja sowieso
dann nimmt man anstatt zwei nimmt mal
fünf fläche mit falls es ja falls es ja
nur schlimmer kommen können
so das ist deutsch die apokalypse klopft
an und der deutsche sagt ich brauch
klopapier
wenn morgen die welt untergeht wollen
wir heute noch in ruhe einen ab sein so
dass tatsache dass tatsache
das ist ja wirklich war das halten uns
nicht ausgedacht am meisten gehamstert
werden nudeln und klopapier was mache
ich bitte mit der kombi warum mich warum
ich meine ist besser als miracoli würde
ich mal sagen so und weil wir ja alle
echte panik vermeiden wollen vielleicht
mal ein kleiner unvermeidlicher hin
verbindlicher hinweis an uns medien
es ist idiotisch von und zitiere
geplünderten regalen zu reden oder zu
schreiben geplündert und sprachlich mal
ganz sauber auseinander zu halten
freunde wenn ein mord mit fackeln und
mistgabeln bei rewe durch die glastüren
tja und dann alles klopapier abräumt und
natürlich sämtliche nudel vorräte also
außer vollkornnudeln natürlich dass
solche frist kein schwein so und danach
dann ohne zu bezahlen durch eine andere
glastür wieder raus rennt das nennt man
plündern so wenn oma horstmanns kötter
klopapier nudeln nimmt beides an der
kasse bezahlt ja und dann kommt
irgendwann pünktlicher typ und füllt das
regal nach das nennt man einen kaufen
einkaufen blühen dann den vorteil dass
wir stellen ja
und wirklich ganz viele zeitung
geschrieben gewesen so aber seien wir
für alles in allem kann man trotzdem
relativ zufrieden sein mit unserer
deutschen corona berichterstattung vor
allem wenn ich bedenke was so im us
fernsehen läuft
nein es sei denn natürlich mal besteht
die berühmten acht kostbarkeiten alto
mit aktuell haben wir in deutschland
knapp 600 corona infizierte die zahl
steigt relativ fix und als
schutzmaßnahmen bleiben momentan
eigentlich weiter nur hände waschen und
kontakt vermeidung die kanzlerin macht
das zum beispiel schon ziemlich
konsequent
hier hält sie sich an ihrer mappe fest
damit sie keine flosse drücken muss
philipp am tag fasst sie grundsätzlich
nicht an aber gar nicht wie ein crooner
sondern den jugendschutz und horst
seehofer hätte sie gerne angefasst aber
ihm was zu ähnlich
lasst mich in ruhe
sehr oft gesagt fast mit einem auto
fingern
übrigens meine absoluten lieblings
schlagzeile stand diese woche in der
bild -zeitung corona alarm im kölner
knast jva komplett abgeriegelt stelle
sich das mal vor die werden da
eingesperrt die leute wie im knast im
grunde so jetzt zu den etwas
schlechteren nachrichten corona
verdachtsfälle telefonieren in
deutschland teilweise tagelang durch die
gegend um herauszufinden wer bei ihnen
einen test machen könnte das läuft noch
ein bisschen chaotisch und für deutsches
pflegepersonal und ärzte fehlt immer
noch schutzkleidung ja muss man halt
improvisieren eine kollegin von mir
wusste sich das nacht nicht anders zu
helfen als die eigene private
taucherbrille zu holen
hier ist eine top idee ist so eine top
idee sollen die ärzte einfach mal im
keller gucken vielleicht liegt da noch
opas alte rüstung
man muss jetzt immer dazu sagen es ist
halt ein neues virus eine völlig neue
erfahrung für uns alle natürlich gibt es
da ja jede menge unsicherheit und
unheimliche begegnungen in quarantäne
hotels stellen sie sich vor sie sind im
urlaub in einem hotel und mitten in der
nacht klopfte es an die tür und jemand
will bei ihnen fieber messen
klingt irgendwie geil ich mir auch
passiert bitte viele menschen in
deutschland fragen sich inzwischen wie
lange stehen die fabriken in china denn
noch still
woher kriege ich mein nächstes iphone
woher freunde ja jetzt wo die
jetzt wo die lohnsklaven in china nicht
mehr in die fabriken gehen problem
deutschland als exportnation ist
natürlich besonders verwöhnt war
besonders abhängig von funktionierenden
lieferketten verstehe sie einfach von
heute alles ja mit allem verwoben ist
wie erklärt man das kind gerecht
[Musik]
so kinder folgendes problem weil in
unserer globalisierten welt medikamente
fast nur noch in indien und china
produziert werden könnte es bald zu
engpässen kommen
ist euch egal er verstehe und das die
ganze weltwirtschaft in schieflage gerät
wegen der abhängigkeit von china ist
euch auch rumpel gut dann vielleicht mal
folgende info sämtliche spiele konsolen
kommen aus asien
sony hat gerade die präsentation der
neuen playstation fünf abgesagt ab die
es verstand
kleine kinder zum heulen gebracht scheck
meine damen und herren so und wir
schalten live zu alexander wipprecht er
ist hysterie beauftragter eben berliner
gesundheitsministerium recht wie hält
sich denn unsere bevölkerung gerade so
an der alten hysterie front auch in
sachen co ohne angst hatten wir uns
eigentlich ganz wacker herweck gut hier
um die ecke in kreuzberg da gab es heute
mal kurz etwas unruhe weil bei aldi die
letzte rolle für das klopapier super
fleisch verkauft wurde hier
dafür musste ich drei renten
niederschlagen das war es wert
insgesamt gibt es wirklich nur kleinere
anzeichen von panik zb in unseren
supermärkten gibt es plötzlich dosen
brot kann sich die deutschen kaufen brot
in dosen
laut genfer konvention verboten können
sie höchstens als türstopper benutzen
das gesündeste ist die dose da ist viel
eisen drin was ich nicht wirklich frage
ob unsere schutzmaßnahmen ausreichen
wenn hier leute einreisen sagen wir mal
aus china oder dem iran moment also das
haben wir ja geregelt alle einreisenden
werden direkt medizinisch untersucht
also ja jetzt nicht von ärzten aber von
fachpersonal die bahn wird verpflichtet
fahrgäste mit corona symptomen den
behörden zu melden
außerdem müssen reisende aussteiger
karten ausfüllen damit sie auch später
noch erreichbar sind so unähnlich der
zugbegleiter beobachtet die passagiere
und sobald ihm da einer irgendwie
komisch vorkommt wird meldung gemacht
aha ist jetzt ausdrücklich nicht böse
gemeint aber wie soll denn ein schaffner
erkennen ob jemand krone hat also das
ist ja überhaupt kein problem für einen
geschulten zugbegleiter gerade bei
schlafenden passagieren also nach 34
riesling im bordrestaurant kannst du
problemlos rektal fiebermessen das
merken die guards
ja was ich nicht verstehe ist aber die
aussteiger karte da schreiben die
reisenden drauf wurde als nächstes
hingehen und wen sie treffen dass sie an
sich schön aber ich kann noch alles
möglich jeder drauf schreiben wer soll
das denn überprüfen wie wer soll das
überprüfen
das war eine blöde frage das machen
natürlich auch die schaffner die steigen
kurz aus und folgen dem verdächtigen wo
ist das problem
der zug muss so lange warten aber das
kennen unsere banken verschluckt scheiße
die korona die korona schaffen
freunde ich habe nicht wirklich habe
nicht verstummt nein ich schwöre ich bin
gesund lassen sich nicht lassen sie das
wir werden dich nie vergessen meine
damen und herren und alle sobald wir
eine millionen abonnenten haben liebe
liebe liebe fans ich würde mich so was
schon freuen wenn ihr ein abo dallas er
würde den gern mag so wird unglücklich
macht